taika yeah what are we gonna oh thank
you look at cutie what are we gonna do
today
i'm going on a trip
yay
uh well they're not gonna move it's not
a moving train
okay
so today we are gonna be checking out
traveltown
[Music]
but before we start exploring we need to
take the paint break
for the monkey man yes please don't
touch anything hold on i have to push
each other for him i got you one second
we'll be back
what's up
[Music]
let's go let's go check it out
and how about we go on it yeah let's go
on it you can go on all of them what
should you want to go on first um follow
me okay i'll follow you
no you can't
some of these trains have ran for
hundreds of years look at that
these are
so cool looking look at these color
schemes are pretty rad too
taika you can get on the union pacific
are you ready dude
okay let's go
okay so we did the trains they're kind
of wack so i'm bringing tyka to a place
i've never been before and it's the
discovery cube
so we're going to discover some stuff
today let's go
okay who's that silly
he looks worried to me
he looks silly because he's worried so
much you got that right okay okay
okay what else uh
mad
happy
sad and we again she looks jealous
what does she look all sad
she's like
where do you want to go let's go
wherever you want to go okay let's go
literally just saw all of them do any of
them look like the ones that you just
saw
oh
[Music]
he's the earth dj
[Music]
i have my mom right there fixing her
shoes
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
keep going keep going
good job
so now taika is gonna go shopping and
we're gonna go to the bakery
yeah you have to go scan it okay but
make sure you wait for everyone because
there's a big line wait a minute wait a
minute cool cake
yeah we gotta find what do we gotta find
a blueberry muffin blueberry look at
that big one
you need help pushing the cart no okay
you got it
there you go
well let's see where the blueberry
muffins
[Music]
now
now tech is going to play a garbage jam
so for every right piece of garbage that
he throws away his truck is going to
move forward and he's going to be
competing against other people in other
stations like that lady
and these people
yeah
okay so get ready in 30 seconds the
game's about to start so this conveyor
belt's about to start
and i think it's going to tell you what
to what is that
are you ready it's gonna start soon
here we go
this thing is cool
[Music]
i should have been listening to the
rules
ready five
four three
two
one okay here we go
how to play
exactly listen to the rules okay
that one up there
here's
those items that are considered
household hazardous waste
wow this is so educational but it looks
so fun
find the start of your selected item and
touch it to the big yellow star on the
trash bins not yet not yet
and watch the
i'm sorry
okay now this one um
oh no the tornado's eating up taika
someone saved him
what do i do
more red
oh no no no i put it back inside oh no
oh
you're back inside
go don't stick your hand in there
okay go
see all the look at all those circles
go do it again
you have to wait till that hit so that
more smoke accumulates okay wait
and push it
push it down
good job dude
not
that wasn't that high
you got scared
okay
no way dude you could do it all by
yourself
monkey
how do you look when you feel sadness go
that's it
how do you look when you feel disgust
that's disgust how do you look when you
feel joy
how do you look when you feel fear
that's fear
how do you look when you feel angry
okay ready be sad go
sad sad said oh you're too happy
he said to the sad part to go up
sad
you're too happy dude
okay too angry
okay so now we are back home had some
dinner and taika wants to show you guys
something funny
this is like the sixth time they showed
me
[Music]
i wonder what it is
[Music]
[Music]
oh god
again okay anyway
a piece of bread we don't do anything
too
[Music]
all right y'all it is about
10 30 at night the monkey dude is
finally in bed
had a really nice day um just exploring
different parts of la with the young
tykes
pogba wasn't here he is in nevada right
now um he just had a lot of work to do
and since type is out of summer school
now like that was the last day um and
friday
i just missed my family so i was like
paw bear is it okay
if you know me and tyka go to california
first you get some work done because
you're so backed up
i spent some time with my family
and then you meet us
on
tuesday because we have a barbell
brigade shoot on wednesday so he is
going to miss 4th of july with us
this is the first year ever and also
because um i want to spend
as much time out here while tyka is on a
summer break
um so that you know he can be here with
his cousins
and
um
you know i can also do a lot more work
in the office while he's with his cousin
so like everyone benefits from it and
papa was gonna come but since papa's
papa is living with us he like we both
thought it was like
really sad to just kind of like leave
his dad there for like weeks at a time
um we did consider getting an airbnb but
then it kind of defeated the whole
purpose of us all being over here so
that i could spend more time with my
family and his cousins
so as you can see there was a lot of
thinking that was involved so i think
what's gonna happen i'm not sure yet is
that um
i might stay out here for a month and
papa will be going back and forth every
other week or at least every week um and
then if i need to shoot anything out in
vegas i'll just fly out there but for
the most part i might be staying out
here so you might be seeing this room
a lot more because um you know i'm
staying with my mom right now and it's
been the [ __ ] best like my mom is by
herself
so like
and actually she prefers it that way but
what up jesus
my dog anyway um
but she definitely enjoys when tyka's
here when i'm here
i don't know how she'll feel about us
being here for a month because my mom's
just like me and a big introvert and
like
people drain
her energies so i am very mindful of
that and i will be very respectful of
that
um
but so far she seems to be really about
the one month i don't know how i feel
about that yet
so i didn't even tell tyke about the one
month i was like we're gonna be here for
eight days he's like yeah
i mean you guys saw his dance
so
yeah we'll see how it all goes but all i
can say is right now it's always filling
my cup to be back with my family this is
something i always wanted growing up
having a big
united family and although my family
isn't the most united that i would like
it to be it is far greater than it was
when i really wanted it so
everything's getting better as i get
older as we all get older as we start
noticing things are
you know emotions are fleeting things
that we did in our past don't really
matter i hope that's something that you
can also remember that like
at the end of the day
what is the goal if the goal is
happiness how do we achieve happiness
happiness comes through community family
love
helping other people
if those are the things then all these
little like disagreements or
he said she said or view points or
whatever the [ __ ] can i go out the
window if the goal is
to have a really united and happy
community around you so
as i'm learning to navigate it myself i
hope i can
you know shed some light
in areas in your life that are similar
to mine where you're like oh
that's true
i see what geo did maybe i can apply to
mine so i'll always share everything
that i possibly can
um in any of my healing in any of my
relationships and anything that i've
ever learned i will continue
to share
with you
but until then this bed is [ __ ]
calling me you know what i'm saying
i hit
11 000 steps today my goal was to hit
eight so i'm above the goal
um that i was set out to do
i trained today
bonded with my mama bonded with my son
did a lot of good stuff today my heart
feels really full my mind feels really
full in a good way
i'm ready to hit the hay you know what
i'm saying
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you had a beautiful day and if not
tomorrow's a brand new day so you let it
all go
start fresh tomorrow
till next time